people have been sending me tweets from
at bad legal takes for a while and i've
really been enjoying them and one of the
ones that got my attention was
originally a tweet from prageru who asks
is the death penalty ever moral and i'm
sure prageru has an opinion on the
subject but the thing that got the most
attention was the reply from red-headed
mermaid who tweeted no one gets the
death penalty that didn't agree to it
with their attorney present
you watch too many movies
i don't know where she could have gotten
this
idea i suppose that we all agree to the
legal system through the social contract
that's kind of a philosophical fiction
yeah i mean you're convicted
involuntarily you're then sentenced
involuntarily
no one really agrees to the death
penalty i mean there have been a handful
of situations where
people have refused a pardon or
requested the death penalty for
political reasons but those are the
exceptions not the rule no one else
really agrees to the death penalty now
you know